überleitung zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt 13 lieferketten
gesetz auch sehr umstritten und lässt
auch eine interessante diskussion
erwarten das geht ja darum dass deutsche
unternehmen mehr sorgfalt bei ihren
zulieferern auf mehr sorgfalt bei ihren
zulieferern wie achten sollen sieht vor
allen dingen um die globale lieferkette
und im bereich von rund 100 zuschauer
und anderen mittag nach deutschland
gebracht werden im ausland hergestellt
oder weiterverarbeitet werden
[Applaus]
erste rednerin neueinstellungen erster
redner zu diesem thema ist herr
präsident sascha rhade von der spd
obmann im ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung jetzt ich
acht jahre
das furchtbare unglück von reiner plasa
als in bangladesch eine textilfabrik
zusammenbrach und über 1200 menschen das
leben verloren vor allem junge frauen
ich war ein jahr später im jahr 2014 mit
zwei kollegen vor ort und habe natürlich
auch mit den überlebenden gesprochen
aber ich sage ihnen vielleicht das
bitterste und eindringlichste erlebnis
was sich in den ganzen 19 jahren noch
dienstreisen bisher hatte war als wir zu
dem unglücksort gegangen sind
da war immer noch über ein jahr später
ein trümmerfeld in dem die toten noch
nicht geborgen waren
das heißt sie stehen dort auf erde auch
stein auf trümmern unten drunter liegen
noch die toten menschen und dann sehen
sie zwischen den steinen
aus der erde herausragend marken
etiketten preisschilder von in
deutschland und europa bekannten
textilfirmen und sie wissen sie sind
dabei sich in einem textilgeschäft wenn
sie diese marken etiketten sehen sie
stehen auf einem friedhof und ich sage
ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn man sowas hautnah gespürt und
erlebt lässt dann das nicht los und dann
weiß man auch dass wir in der
verantwortung haben dass so etwas
niemals wieder passiert meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
und deswegen bin ich dankbar dass
entwicklungsminister müller gemeinsam
mit hubertus heil unserem
arbeitsminister gekämpft haben dass wir
jetzt gegen viele widerstände auch von
wirtschaftsseite auch leider vom
wirtschaftsminister jetzt ein
gesetzentwurf vorlegen der unternehmen
in die verantwortung nimmt damit sie
eben ihre menschenrechtlichen
sorgfaltspflichten künftig einhalten
müssen damit verantwortung nicht weiter
nur freiwillig ausgeübt werden darf
und nochmal herzlichen dank dafür und
ich weiß auch dass der tu in seiner
fraktion dafür geleistet hast aber
hubertus mit seinen ganzen vielen
vorhaben da auch bis tief in die nacht
zu gekämpft hat ganz ganz vielen
herzlichen dank dafür
und das ist heute ein historischer tag
weil dort dann wirklich von der
freiwilligkeit zu einer gesetzlichen
regelung kommen der menschenrechte
dürfen nicht freiwillige angelegenheit
sein soll es muss eine pflicht sein und
eine selbstverständlichkeit sein dass
menschenrechte eingehalten werden und
ich möchte an dieser stelle sagen all
diejenigen die jetzt sagen ja die
regierungen sollen doch dafür sorgen
dass mensch und arbeitnehmerrechte
eingehalten werden da sind die gleichen
kräfte die immer wenn es darum geht die
handelsverträge gerecht zu machen
nämlich mit sanktionsmechanismen bei
verstößen sich auch dagegen sperren und
auch
der minister altmaier vertritt diese
position nein ich sage wir brauchen
faire handelsabkommen wo verstöße gegen
menschen- und arbeitsrechte sanktioniert
werden die regierungen müssen die
verantwortung übernehmen aber die
unternehmen dürfen sich da nicht ihrer
verantwortung entziehen nach dem motto
wenn mich keiner kontrolliert kann ich
machen was ich will
deswegen ist heute eine historische
stunde dass wir diesen gesetzentwurf
einbringen und das wird dazu führen dass
millionen kinder nicht mehr schuften
müssen auch für kakao plantagen und
wären konsumieren ist schon dass
menschen keine hungerlöhne mehr gezahlt
bekommen dass ausbeute und
wettbewerbsvorteil mehr sein darf dafür
werden wir kämpfen und diesen
gesetzentwurf durchbringen ja das radl
seien gestorben weil die beiden ersten
rede diese debatte anwesend waren als es
losging der spd und markus frohnmeyer
von der afg jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wer jetzt kommt und wer jetzt wann ist
im ablauf das jetzt marcus schon mal von
der afg weil sascha rabe offenbar für
seinen parteifreund hubertus heil erst
mal gesprochen hat von der spd und jetzt
marcus hohlmeier afd in der diskussion
um das lieferketten gesetz vielen dank
herr präsident
man kann es eigentlich fast gar nicht
mehr hören wie über so ernste themen
immer wieder gesprochen wird was soll
denn an der stelle immer das
moralisieren kollege habe sie müssen
doch den leuten da draußen mal erklären
was dieses lieferketten gesetz
eigentlich bedeutet und ist
ausschließlich deutsche unternehmen
deutsche unternehmen sollen dazu
verpflichtet werden überall auf der welt
soziale und ökologische standards
durchzusetzen eine verschiebung
weg von den entwicklungsländern also
deren regierungen hin zu ausschließlich
deutschen unternehmen
die sollen dann so eine art lieferketten
polizei global machen das muss man sich
doch mal überlegen wie soll denn das
funktionieren das ist doch völlig absurd
was sie hier heute versuchen umzusetzen
meine damen und herren es ist auch ein
angriff auf alle deutschen unternehmer
da draußen die sich trauen im ausland zu
investieren die schon jetzt lange die
höchsten standards und bereich der
ökologie und wenn es um soziale fragen
an den tag legt geht legen und ich kann
nicht nachvollziehen warum man hier so
etwas auf diese art und weise
qualifizieren will
und da muss man sich doch mal die frage
stellen wieso was in der praxis aussieht
wie soll so was in der praxis
funktionieren
nehmen wir doch mal ein unternehmer der
meinetwegen halbleiter teile herstellt
er hat 15 oder 20 mitarbeiter und als
kunden hat er jetzt ein unternehmen das
unter ihrer lieferketten gesetz fällt
ich hatte die gelegenheit mit jemandem
darüber zu sprechen den es betreffen
wird da wird doch dann das unternehmen
das das lieferketten gesetz jetzt zu
beachten hat natürlich auch darauf
drängen dass die zulieferer die kleinen
mit 15 20 30 mitarbeitern in der lage
sind dieses lieferketten gesetz mit zu
beachten weil es geht ja nur so dass das
große unternehmen dass darunter fällt
dann natürlich auch beim zulieferer
darauf besteht dass er in der lage ist
diese lieferkette entsprechend mit
transparent zu gestalten
glauben sie dass inzwischen frage
aussage die ich möchte jetzt zu ende
machen was sagt denn die cdu dazu das
muss man sich doch einfach mal anschauen
es ist keine keine zwei monate her dass
wir hier standen und ein kollege mit dem
namen level
gesagt hat ich zitiere mit erlaubnis des
präsidenten man muss für unsere fraktion
ganz klar sagen ein lieferketten gesetz
auf nationaler ebene ist nicht der weg
den wir einschlagen wollen
zitat ende meine damen und herren von
der cdu 15 tage hat es gedauert nur 15
tage hat es gedauert bis sie umgefallen
sind
herzlichen glückwunsch sie haben der fdp
als umfallerpartei wirklich den rang
abgelaufen
und eines muss man an der stelle
vielleicht auch mal noch sagen was
bedeutet den entwicklungspolitisch wir
hatten so war es ja schon mal die
amerikaner haben im rahmen des dort
frank dass auch geregelt es haben sich
daraufhin amerikanische unternehmen
beispielsweise aus dem kongo
zurückgezogen dann wurde platz frei und
den haben die chinesen eingenommen
arbeitsplätze sind verloren gegangen und
die arbeitsbedingungen für die menschen
dort vor ort haben sich verschlechtert
das ist doch die realität die man
beachten muss also in summe
sie plündern und zersetzen die deutsche
wirtschaft mit diesem gesetz sie sorgen
dafür dass es den menschen in den
entwicklungsländern schlechter geht das
ist gutmenschentum in reinkultur meine
damen und herren und das werden wir in
der form nicht mittragen
ich komme dann zum ende und bitte sie
dass sie wirklich noch mal darüber
nachdenken ob sie solche gesetzentwürfe
hier diskutieren wollen
es kann nicht sein dass deutsche
unternehmen plötzlich weltweit die
lieferketten polizei machen sollen das
ist eine aufgabe von regierungen dafür
zu sorgen dass auf dem eigenen
staatsgebiet arbeitnehmerrechte
ökologische und soziale standards
durchgesetzt werden und nicht
ausschließlich eine aufgabe deutscher
unternehmen meine damen und herren
entwurf der bundesregierung heißt es
dass deutschen unternehmen verpflichtet
werden sollen ihrer globalen
verantwortung für die achtung von
menschenrechten umweltstandards besser
nachzukommen
dieses gesetz übersee um städten
innerhalb der koalition vor allen dingen
zwischen peter altmaier
wirtschaftsminister und dem
arbeitsminister hubertus heil und auf
der seite von hubertus heil zu sein von
der anderen partei war aber der zieht
von der csu kommende
entwicklungsminister gerd müller und er
spricht jetzt zu diesem thema das die
soziale frage des 21 jahrhunderts
ob wir vom freien zum fairen handel in
globalen lieferketten kommen
sascha raabe und ich wir haben rana
blaser die trümmer gesehen heute ist der
tag acht jahre du hast das gesagt 1138
frauen haben ihr leben unter den
trümmern verloren und das skandal war
die frauen haben zwei tage davor darauf
hingewiesen die risse in den mauern
haben sich gezeigt dass management hat
angewiesen
ihr habt keine rechte gehabt weiter zu
arbeiten für 14 cent in der stunde
arbeitet er hier 14 stunden am tag sechs
tage die woche und sie gingen ins
verderben wir gedenken heute der toten
frauen von rana blaser
und ich sage ihnen die würde ein anderer
mensch und ein anderer politiker wenn
sie mit den überlebenden sprechen
mein blick auf profitmaximierung in der
globalisierung des handels im
internationalen lieferketten hat sich
geändert externalisierung und
auslagerung der produktion in den
entwicklungsländern
das kann nicht unser globales
wirtschaftsmodell sein
meine damen und herren wir können und
dürfen nicht die augen verschließen vor
ausbeutung von kindern mensch und natur
und das ist nicht nur reiner plasa
textil sondern das geht weit darüber
hinaus ob es die versorgung von mehr man
rufen umwelt von öl multis im nigerdelta
ist oder die ausbeutung von kindern auf
kaffee kakao baumwollplantagen oder für
unsere grabsteine in steinbrüchen ich
sage dass hier sehr deutlich
ich habe auch diese kinder getroffen in
indien die befreit wurden aus diesem
loch und ich habe ihm versprochen
wir helfen euch und wir ändern wir tun
was notwendig ist
80 millionen kinder arbeiten als
arbeitssklaven für uns die reichen auf
der sonnenseite des planeten für unsere
produkte
meine damen und herren wir haben
zusammen
hubertus heil und ich die
koalitionsfraktionen das deutsche
bündnis umgesetzt auf der basis von
freiwilligkeit sind 50 prozent dabei und
wenn sie heute in der zeitschrift
textilwirtschaft nachlesen dann freut
mich das ganz besonders dass auch die
verbände die textilwirtschaft zeichen
setzen maßstäbe setzen es geht
große und kleine firmen können im
zeitalter der digitalisierung
lieferketten verfolgen eine pionierin
ist am tier von lienz schauen sie sich
diesen betrieb an der grünen knopf am
tier von dem jetzt gebt 30 jahre voraus
ein kleines unternehmen zeigt es geht
gerechtigkeit in den lieferketten
umzusetzen
und deshalb danke ich diesen pionieren
ich danke den kirchen und der
welthungerhilfe dem dgb aber allen die
mitgeholfen haben
wir haben diesen ersten richtigen
schritt nur gemeinsam geschafft mit
vielen angeles und vielen die uns
unterstützen und gemeinsam wir beide
autos heil und ich sein team voba tus
wir haben wie freuen wir und wir sind
freunde geworden dieses projekt auf dem
jahr
wir haben ihn kopieren denn auch er hat
sich verändert als in äthiopien mit
frauen gesprochen hat also die realen
zustände gesehen haben
meine damen und herren das lieferketten
gesetz kommt ein langes ringen ein guter
kompromiss
hermann gröhe und meine freundinnen
unionsfraktion werden auf details
eingehen
wichtig ist ein verbot von kinderarbeit
umzusetzen die stärkung der
menschenrechte
und dies ohne die wirtschaft zu
überfordern
dieses gesetz geht ab 20 23 darauf
arbeitsminister eingehen wir haben eine
übergangsfrist wir haben
mittelstandsfreundlich das ganze
gestaltet es ist umsetzbar in einer
abgestuften verantwortung das ist die
deutsche initiative für eine vorlage der
eu kommission diese initiative muss zur
basis einer europäischen regelung werden
standard sozial und ökologisch müssen
standard weltweit werden weltweit meine
damen und herren nicht nur in der
produktion industrie auch bei
dienstleistungen auf bei
finanzdienstleistungen wto wird und muss
folgen
ich habe dr nico sind die neue
vorsitzende vor 14 tagen besucht sie
steht dass migranten an der spitze für
einen neuen kurs der wto für einen
gerechten globalisierung wir stehen an
ihrer seite
der freie welthandel muss ein fairer
welthandel werden
und die un menschenrechtsrat haben und
dass die stg agenda ist er weg in eine
bessere gerechtere globalisierung und zu
kommt deshalb machen wir unsere politik
enkel tauglich und schöpfungs tauglich
heute am girls day ist aus lieferketten
gesetz unser beitrag dazu herzlichen
dame diese sind als beginn einer großen
freundschaft zwischen müller von der csu
und hubertus heil von der spd dieses
freundschaftsangebot werden viele in der
fraktion von gap müller also der cdu csu
fraktion mit gemischten gefühlen
beobachtet haben da war dieses gesetz ja
sehr umstritten und ist es auch noch
gerd müller muss er noch dazu sagen wird
dem neuen bundestag nicht mehr angehören
nächster redner carl julius cronenberg
von der fdp
nein
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
heute geht es um menschenrechte und den
kampf gegen kinderarbeit
dazu will die bundesregierung deutschen
unternehmen ein risikomanagement und
dokumentationspflichten auferlegen
mein gefühl sagt mir millionen kinder in
den minen und feldern erwarten
vielleicht etwas anderes als
risikomanagement und
dokumentationspflichten
sie wollen zur schule gehen eine
ausbildung machen und wünschen sich
berufliche perspektiven
die kinder der welt erwarten dass ihre
eltern unter menschenwürdigen
bedingungen arbeiten und dass sich ihr
heimatland an die un leitprinzipien für
menschenrechte hält und wir freien
demokraten stehen dabei an mir beiseite
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir diskutieren wir diskutieren auch
über verantwortung deutscher unternehmen
in der welt die stelle mit bedauern fest
das gesetz atmet den geist des
misstrauens es wird bewusst der eindruck
erweckt kinderarbeit und ausbeutung
würden billigend in kauf genommen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die ganze
welt sich das anders
wohin wir reisen tragen unsere gastgeber
wann kommen die deutschen und
investieren denn die welt weiß deutsche
investitionen bringen faire löhne und
arbeitsbedingungen oft auch aus und
weiterbildung handelt und investitionen
handel und investitionen unserer
unternehmen in entwicklungsländern
schaffen nicht nur arbeitsplätze hier
sie führen auch vielen menschen aus der
armut und perspektivlosigkeit dort
deutsche unternehmen sind teil der
lösung und nicht des problems es ist an
der zeit dass sie das endlich anerkennen
der minister müller
auf die frage des kollegen dr hoffmann
in der regierungsbefragung gestern ob
das gesetz eventuell deutsch
auslandsinvestitionen in
entwicklungsländern behindere lautete
ihre antwort weder ja noch nein
sie antworteten la vida das gesetz ist
ein meilenstein mit verlaub wer die
einführung einer verpflichtung zur
dokumentation über die einhaltung von
sorgfaltspflichten als meilenstein
gefeiert
dem geht es nicht um menschenrechte
sondern der lenkt ab vom scheitern
seiner eigenen entwicklungspolitik der
kapituliert in wahrheit vor den
autokraten dieser welt ein meilenstein
im eurocup ii aufbaut allenfalls die
regierung gibt vor und nur große
unternehmen seien betroffen
das ist entweder augenwischerei oder
ignoranz selbstverständlich werden große
unternehmen ihre mittelständischen
zulieferer in deutschland ebenfalls in
die pflicht nehmen nicht in der pflicht
ist dagegen ermessen genau wie alle
anderen plattformen oder ausländische
unternehmen mit zweigstellen nur in
deutschland
dieses gesetz führt zum rückzug der
anständigen und verdrängte im
mittelstand da müssen sie nachbessern
aber dringend und das geht auch schaffen
die safe harbor lösungen beugen sie
doppel dokumentationen vor
helfen sie mit bei positivlisten
negativlisten und wenn sie dann ein
attraktives paket geschnürt haben dass
die unternehmen motiviert mitzumachen
dann fahren sie nach brüssel und werden
dafür dann haben sie uns an ihrer seite
die kinder in den minen und feldern
werden es ihnen danken der fdp es geht
bei diesem gesetz ja auch nicht nur um
die frage menschenrechte im engeren
sinne es geht um gesundheit angemessenen
lohn und lebensunterhalt die freiheit
von zwangs- und kinderarbeit und
vereinigungsfreiheit das heißt also auch
um die das recht gewerkschaften
bilden zu dürfen um sich gut zu
vertreten wohl gesagt in diesen ländern
meistens in den entwicklungsländern die
deutsche firmen beliefern nächste
rednerin eva maria schreiber von der
fraktion die linke
kolleginnen und kollegen auf den ersten
blick scheint die einigung auf ein
gesetz für menschenrechtliche
sorgfaltspflichten von unternehmen
erfreulich endlich der bis die chance
menschenrechte und gerechtigkeit in der
deutschen wirtschaft stärker zu
verankern und es ist ja auch ein schritt
in die richtige richtung und erster
trotzdem auf druck der
wirtschaftsverbände sowie unter
freundlicher mithilfe des
bundeswirtschaftsministers der ist jetzt
gerade nicht da warum wurde der anfangs
so gute gesetzentwurf massiv verwässert
wieder einmal haben sich die lobbyisten
durchgesetzt die linke will den entwurf
und mehreren punkten nachbessern drei
möchte ich erwähnen
erstens in vollem umfang beziehen sich
sorgfaltspflichten derzeit nur noch auf
direkte vertragspartner
das ist absurd denn die meisten menschen
menschenrechtskonventionen passieren am
anfang der lieferkette und treffen damit
häufig die ärmsten der armen
gerade sie gilt es zu schützen doch zb
in der kurve als mine oder auf den
bananenplantagen müssen unternehmen ihre
risiken nur anlassbezogen ermitteln und
ausschließlich dann etwas unternehmen
wenn sie substantiiert erkenntnis über
eine mögliche menschenrechtsverletzung
erlangen
das ist eine aufforderung zum wegschauen
denn die weniger unternehmen wissen
desto weniger müssen sie handeln
das widerspricht fundamental den
präventiven grundgedanken der
ein leitprinzipien und muss dringend
verändert werden zwei menschen die im
ausland von schäden durch
sorgfaltspflichtverletzungen betroffen
sind müssen vor deutschen gerichten
klagen können nur eine zivilrechtliche
haftungsregeln gewährleistet dieses
recht die geplante ausweitung der
vertretung von betroffenen durch angeles
oder gewerkschaften ist ein ansatz löst
dieses problem aber nicht ohne die
haftung fehlt den gesetzen schärfstes
schwert das prinzip nun mal 14 macht
unmissverständlich klar alle unternehmen
tragen die verantwortung für die achtung
der menschenrechte
bleibt es bei der derzeitigen regelung
von unternehmen ab 1000 mitarbeitenden
wäre von dem gesetz jedoch nur zur k 0,1
prozent der deutschen wirtschaft
betroffen
das darf so nicht sein auch unternehmen
ab 250 mitarbeitenden haben die mitte
sorgfaltspflichten in ihren lieferketten
zu erfüllen und kleine und mittlere
unternehmen in risiko sektoren wie in
der automobil- oder textilindustrie
müssen ebenfalls dazu verpflichtet
werden im rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten
aktiv zu werden
mit diesem gravierenden lücken dürfen
wir dieses gesetz nicht verabschieden
sonst besteht die gefahr dass es kaum
wirkung hat und im schlimmsten falle dem
prozess auf europäischer ebene ebenfalls
aufbessern sie nach
im gesetzentwurf zum lieferketten gesetz
sollen erst anfang 2003 und 20 3 und
auch nur für firmen mit mehr als 2000
beschäftigten gelten ab 2024 sind dann
für mit mehr als 1000 beschäftigten das
würde gerade von der rednerin der linken
eva maria schreiber kritisiert nächster
redner und den kids von bündnis 90 die
grünen werte kolleginnen wir streiten
schon lange gemeinsam mit kirchen
gewerkschaften angeles wissenschaft
national und international für ein
wirksames lieferketten gesetz das die un
vorgaben umsetzt und zu denen wir
eigentlich auch schon lange durch
internationale verträge verpflichtet
sind und ich möchte den ministern teil
und müller danken dass wir heute darüber
sprechen können
aber minister die eine solche fraktion
zum gegner haben die können natürlich
nicht wirklich erfolgreich sein und
deshalb bleibt ihr entwurf auch klar
hinter seinen möglichkeiten zurück
so ist es völlig inakzeptabel dass die
umweltverantwortung nur halbherzig
berücksichtigt wird und die von ihnen
gewählte unternehmensgröße sorgte
letztlich dafür dass die meisten
unternehmen nicht für etwaige
menschenrechtsverstöße zur verantwortung
gezogen werden können und das kredit
gesetz könnte hier sogar als freibrief
verstanden werden besonders schwer wiegt
aber die tatsache dass sie die
zivilrechtliche haftung schlicht
ignorieren
sie warten auf europa das funktioniert
nicht das muss hier umgesetzt werden
entwurf verstößt auch klar gegen die un
leitprinzipien indem sie die lieferkette
im prinzip nur auf die direkten
vertragspartner beschränken und damit
stellen sie gezielt und bewusst
besondere problembereiche wie die
landwirtschaft bergbau fischerei und
anderes außerhalb des gesetzes
diese regierung hat offensichtlich noch
nicht verstanden dass es ihre aufgabe
ist für alle unternehmen die gleichen
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen die
nachhaltig und menschenrechtskonform
sein müssen
ein solches gesetz muss auch dafür
sorgen dass deutsche konsumartikel nicht
mehr durch die länder des globalen
südens subventioniert werden indem übels
der arbeitsbedingungen bei inakzeptable
bezahlung und zu lasten der umwelt ein
wettlauf zu den niedrigsten kosten
stattfindet diese länder zahlen unsere
zeche
hinzu kommt dass eine vorausschauende
politik auf faire beziehungen zu anderen
nationen setzt die beziehungen die auf
ausbeute von billigen arbeitskräften und
ignoranz gegenüber der umwelt passieren
sind nicht nachhaltig sondern schlicht
neokoloniale ein wirksames
sorgfaltspflichten gesetz ist also eine
investition in die zukunft
außerdem ein starkes gesetz schützt
vorbildliche unternehmen gegen umwelt-
und menschenrechts haustüren und genau
darauf hat eine wachsende anzahl
ambitionierter unternehmen die es gibt
auch einen anspruch und diesen müssen
wir auch gerecht werden ihr gesetzt tut
das nicht dann gezündet
so jetzt kommt
debatte wieder in ihrer not denn
hubertus heil der bundesminister
bundesarbeitsminister der eigentlich
zuständig ist er hat ja am anfang der
debatte gefehlt deswegen ging das alles
hier etwas durcheinander jetzt redet und
wartungsfreie ja hinter diesen nieser
gesetze hätten gesetz steht dass es eine
herzensangelegenheit von ihnen gemeinsam
mit dem bundesminister für
entwicklungshilfe von gerd müller von
der csu jetzt hubertus heil
geschäftsordnungs fragen keine minister
sie können mit der beginn der kollege
thomas von mir gerade über die
geschäftslage unterrichtet worden
ganz herzlichen dank sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
kaum ein anderes land in der welt
profitiert so stark von der arbeits
teiligen wirtschaft für unsere
bundesrepublik deutschland das sichert
wohlstand und arbeitsplätze unserem land
aber herr kollege daraus ergeben sich
auch besondere verantwortung für
menschenrechte für anständige
arbeitsbedingungen weltweit für die
globalisierung die wir fair gestalten
wollen und menschlich und ja es gibt
eine staatliche verantwortung in
handelsverträgen beispielsweise oder
auch bei investitionsschutzabkommen um
ein aktuelles europäisches beispiel zu
nennen
zugleich gibt es aber auch
unternehmensverantwortung für
menschenrechte und für ihre arbeit
und genau deshalb ist das lieferketten
gesetz heute ein meilenstein
[Applaus]
der global gewinne machen muss auch
global verantwortung übernehmen und
diesen grundsatz schreiben wir mit
unserem lieferketten gesetz zu künftig
rechtsverbindlich fest weltweit werden
fast 25 millionen menschen in der welt
in zwangsarbeit ausgebeutet 152
millionen kinder sind opfer von
kinderarbeit und die schädigung der
umwelt ist interessant lieferketten als
so oft leider immer noch teil des
geschäftsmodells
meine damen und herren das sind
bedrückende das sind erschütternde
fakten die wir nicht einfach
achselzuckend akzeptieren können und
gerd müller
mein freund hat es erwähnt wir sind
zusammen
es ist ja nicht es ist ja nicht so dass
das eine schande ist dass das in der
politik auch parteiübergreifend sogar in
dieser koalition möglich ist aber was
uns vor allem geprägt hat ist das
wirklich gemeinsam 2009/10 äthiopien
gereist sind und es vor ort ein bild
gemacht hatten
ein bitterarmes land mit dem wir
intensive handelsbeziehungen haben und
wir haben gute beispiele gesehen und wir
haben erschütternde beispiele gesehen
und erlebt was passiert wenn deutsche
unternehmen sich in lieferbeziehungen
kümmern zum beispiel in einer
textilfabrik mit vorbildlichen
arbeitsbedingung mit arbeitsschutz mit
einigermaßen anständigen löhnen mit
mitarbeitervertretungen und wer ein
furchtbares beispiel in einer gerberei
gesehen wo frauen bis zu den knien in
chemikalien standen muss kein
arbeitsschutz kappus hungerlöhne graben
das waren ich sage es bewusst das was
wir vor 150 jahren eine früh
kapitalistische hölle in unserem land
genannt haben wer das gesehen hat meine
damen und herren der weiß es gibt
unternehmerische verantwortung und die
unternehmen die das auch machen aus
deutschland heraus
wie ändern die arbeitsbedingungen auch
in ihren lieferbeziehung das hat ägypten
ist das gesetz
mit dem gesetz machen wir den schutz von
menschenrechten und den schutz von
umwelt zu verbindlichen unternehmerische
standard im gegensatz zu dem was vorhin
erzielt wurde ist umfasst die gesamte
lieferkette was umweltrechtliche und
umweltbezogene menschenrechtliche
risiken betrifft die sind zu überprüfen
und kommen dabei hinweise auf
kinderarbeit sklaven aber als
zwangsarbeit oder die vergiftung lokaler
trinkwasserressourcen zutage
dann muss ein unternehmen zukünftig im
rahmen seiner möglichkeiten reagieren
wir verlangen nicht mehr und nicht
weniger die unternehmerische
sorgfaltspflicht endet eben fühlt sich
nicht mehr am eigenen werk tor sondern
in der gesamten internationalen
lieferkette im eigenen geschäftsbereich
bei den direkten zu liefern aber auch
bei den mittelbaren und meine damen und
herren wir regeln erlässt muss auch
dafür sorgen dass sie eingehalten werden
dieses über die wirksamkeit des gesetzes
ja gesprochen worden ist eben kein
papiertiger sondern eins mit biss denn
das gesetz enthält klare pflichten und
klare regeln und das sieht kontrollen
und substanzielle sanktionen für den
fall vor dass das zuständige bundesamt
für wirtschaft und ausfuhrkontrolle
verstöße fest stellt und wenn es soweit
kommt dann drohen empfindliche zwangs
und bußgeld und bei einer bestimmten
schwelle übrigens zukünftig auch der
ausschluss von unternehmen von der
öffentlichen auftragsvergabe
wir haben das bundesamt für wirtschaft
und ausfuhrkontrolle mit einem robusten
mandat zur durchsetzung versehen
übrigens mit beweissicherungs
möglichkeit mit betreten um dingen auch
nachgehen zu können
deshalb sage ich bei allem was man sich
so wünschen mag
und dieses gesetz kann man sicherlich
zukünftig weiter entwickelt vor allem
wenn es zu einer europäischen regelung
kommen das ist ein wesentlicher schritt
und es ist tatsächlich so dass wir zwar
den zivilrechtlichen haftung für das
deutsche gesetzliche aber ein robustes
mandat mit einer behördlichen
durchsetzung das sollten sie nicht
kleinreden
zumal etwas zweites durchgesetzt haben
was mir persönlich sehr sehr wichtig war
es geht ja auch darum die rechte der
menschen die von
menschenrechtsverletzungen getroffen
sind und über zustand und es gibt schon
einen zivilrechtlichen möglichkeit
theoretisch für menschen vor deutschen
gerichten zu klagen
eine realität des lebens haben aber die
meisten die von solchen
menschenrechtsverletzungen in
lieferketten in anderen ländern
betroffen sind weder die kraft noch das
geld ihre rechte vor deutschen gerichten
geltend zu machen und deshalb ist es ein
riesenfortschritt dass zukünftig
deutsche gewerkschaften deutschen trios
und hilfsorganisationen im namen und im
einverständnis der menschenrechtlich
betroffenen die rechte durchsetzen
können dass meine damen und herren
diskutierten dann zum schluss
wir sorgen auch für fairen wettbewerb
denn es gibt viele unternehmen die sich
kümmern und anstand darf in der
globalisierung kein wettbewerbsnachteil
damit er noch das ist wichtig denn
schluss präsident meine damen und herren
unsere soziale marktwirtschaft fußt auf
dem prinzip der wirtschaft haben sie
eine frage
präsident schuldigen dass ihre aufgabe
das minister ich weiß nicht wie es der
bundesregierung ist aber im deutschen
bundestag nicht ist er präsident der
jenige der fragen zulässt im zweifel als
sie müssen natürlich auch zu lassen aber
da ihre redezeit bereits deutlich ab
gelaufen ist macht es keinen sinn sie um
die dadurch zu verlängern das design
zwischenfrage aus der fdp fraktion
gestellt wird schade dass da kommen sie
kommen sie bitte zum ende
dass sie mit regeln wenig zu tun haben
wollte mir ein aber ich bin gehalten
geschäftsordnung zu beraten
spektive natürlich ihre rechte und auch
das recht vor kurzem interventionen zum
schluss meine damen und herren die
soziale marktwirtschaft in deutschland
die fußt auf dem prinzip von
wirtschaftlichen handel und
gesellschaftlicher verantwortung
in diesem sinne bitte ich sie diesen
gesetzentwurf in der parlamentarischen
beratung zum durchbruch zu verhelfen
wir haben nur noch vier sitzungswochen
zeit aber dieses gesetz macht im übrigen
auch rückenwind für eine europäische
lösung und damit leisten wir einen
beitrag zur gerechteren globalisieren
herzlichen dank geraucht trotz der
ernsthaftigkeit dieses thema ist eine
bestimmung im bundestag zum lieferketten
gesetze hubertus heil der bundesminister
von der spd bundesarbeitsminister der
mehrfach seinen freund gerd müller von
der csu den bundesminister für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
angesprochen
der bundesminister für dieses
lichterketten gesetzt der fehlt hier das
feld auf das ist peter altmaier der
bundesminister für wirtschaft aber der
hat ja auch an diesem lieferketten
ketten gesetz große kritik geübt und es
geht ihm offensichtlich auch viel zu
weit wir werden jetzt weiter sehen wie
die debatte sich mit dem letzten redner
entwickelt das es hermann gröhe von der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
also bundesminister hd und
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der cdu/csu-fraktion und nach diesem
weltweit war gibt es eine wechsel hotel
hier am mikrofon man politiker die auch
in von verlor bei uns nicht damit ab das
millionenfach menschenrechte in
ausbeuterischen arbeitsverhältnissen mit
füßen getreten werden damit finden wir
uns nicht ab kinder gehören in die
schule nicht ins bergwerk nicht auf die
plantage und nicht auf den sportplatz
das 1
doch die allermeisten und in wahrheit
auch die allermeisten in der wirtschaft
deswegen ist es albern uns zu
unterstellen wir hätten einen
generalverdacht gegen die wirtschaft ich
kenne viele eindrucksvolle beispiele
unternehmerischer verantwortung gerade
in entwicklungsländern
aber wir hören doch gerade auch von
diesen unternehmerinnen unternehmer dass
wir mehr konsequenz mehr systematisches
hinschauen brauchen sie rufen nach
klaren verbindlichen rahmen für alle
wegschauen darf kein wettbewerbsvorteil
sein meine damen meine herren
und deutschland ist größter importeur in
der welt diese marktmacht gibt uns die
möglichkeit standards zu setzen und aus
dieser möglichkeit wird angesichts
schrecklicher menschenrechtsverletzung
eine gemeinsame verpflichtung von staat
und wirtschaft und übrigens auch von uns
allen als verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher die sich für die herkunft
ihrer produkte interessieren sollten
meine damen meine herren
für mich war immer klar ein lieferketten
gesetz muss wirksam seien für die
menschenrechte es muss auch zweitens
umsetzbar sein
für die wirtschaft es muss wirksam sein
es muss einen echten fortschritt für die
menschenrechte bringen
und ja das bedeutet aufwand aber ehrlich
gesagt dass so in der attitüde
schnickschnack bürokratisches monster zu
diffamieren wird der ernsthaftigkeit
millionenfacher menschenrechtsverletzung
nicht gerecht meine damen und übrigen
wenn es um unseren schutz geht
qualitätssicherung entlang der ganzen
lieferkette
dann erscheint uns der aufwand
selbstverständlich angemessen geht es ja
auch um unseren schutz und deswegen ist
es falsch hier das in bausch und bogen
abzulehnen natürlich kollege konnte die
dokumentation schützt nicht das kind
aber das was dokumentiert wird nämlich
die verpflichtung auf den zulieferer
zuzugehen und sich für die
arbeitsverhältnisse dort zu
interessieren
dies ist ein wichtiger schritt diesen
kinder zu helfen den sie nicht schlecht
reden
ich will umsetzbarkeit ja denn wir
wollen mehr investitionen zum beispiel
in afrika mehr fairen handel mit afrika
und deswegen ist es wichtig zu wissen
dass jobs und ausbildung durch solchen
handel durch wirtschaftsbeziehungen
stehen nur zu geringen teil durch
entwicklungszusammenarbeit wahr ist aber
auch staatliche entwicklungshilfe kann
ich die wunden heilen die ausbeuterische
wirtschaftsbeziehungen erst schlagen
insofern gibt es eben eine gemeinsame
zusammen habt verantwortung
wir haben viel an zustimmung wir haben
auch kritik von ngo s von gewerkschaften
von wirtschaftsverbänden
wir nehmen das ernst wir prüfen das im
verfahren aber ich sage sehr deutlich
karikaturen schlechte karikaturen und
verzerrende darstellungen dies gegen das
gesetz insgesamt gibt weisen wir
entschieden zurück meine damen und
herren dem selbstverständlich spielt
auch in diesem gesetz der
rechtsstaatliche grundsatz unmögliches
darf nicht verlangt werden
deswegen steht eindeutig im gesetz und
seiner
dass die sorgfaltspflichten einer
bemühens pflicht konstituieren es geht
wird ausdrücklich das konkret machbare
und angemessener als maßstab benannt das
ist richtig das mag man vielleicht noch
weiter präzisieren wenn es etwa auf
abhilfemaßnahmen geht da wo die
menschenrechtsverletzung nicht dass bei
ihm beeinflussbaren verhalten des
zulieferers begründet ist sondern in
einer rechtsordnung eines staates sander
der abbruch von geschäftsbeziehung
verlangt werden kann und wann
sinnvollerweise nicht aber der grundsatz
dass angemessen und konkret machbar das
ist was verlangt wird steht eindeutig im
gesetz
meine damen meine herren ja wir haben
uns entschieden und ich glaube das ist
gut vertretbar die zivilrechtliche
haftung durch ein app die zusätzliche
zivilrechtliche haftung nicht vor zu
sehen sondern ein effektives bußgeld und
sanktionssystem
ich glaube sogar dass das in mancherlei
hinsicht wirksamer sein kann und
deswegen sollten wir diesen weg gehen er
kollegen die zwischenfrage spiel in
foren meyer aus den heimischen glaube
ich nicht weil ich da bisher keine
ernsthafte auseinandersetzung mit dem
thema erlebt lassen sie dich noch zum
thema unternehmensgröße etwas sagen ja
auch das war ein kompromiss wir wollen
die mittelstand gerade in dieser zeit
nicht zusätzlich belasten habe ich will
hier sehr offen sagen für die frage ob
wir nicht um selbstständige töchter also
niederlassung hier und betriebsstätten
ausländischer konzerne einbeziehen
sollten da bin ich durchaus bereit das
sollten wir im gesetzgebungsverfahren
drüber redet es sollte nicht von der
unterschiedlichen rechtsformen abhängen
dass wir in deutschland über diesen
schweren werten arbeit hat auch dran ist
sich diesen rahmenbedingungen zu stellen
das lässt wegen der gestaltungsräume das
eröffnet mehr fairen wettbewerb sie
sehen wir haben einen guten
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt als regierung
dafür danke ich den beiden
freundinnen gewesen und wir werden
gemeinsam im parlament zu einem
erfolgreichen gesetz machen
vielen dank